citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to complete another continuity you
thought after dcam you would be a long
time till we finish something up but nay
there's a sequel to A movie we watched
two movies ago we are about to watch
Justice League Doom which is part two to
Justice League crisis on Two Earths so
we got some sets of sequels going on
I've never seen it John's never seen it
never seen it very excited about it you
know how this works you leave a like you
leave a comment you hit that chair you
tell your friends and family you love
and care about them because it's
important to do so as often as possible
because you never know when you're gonna
die and while we watch Justice League
Doom you know what you could wear a bet
for a shirt because you know who's in
this the Batman and the bad verse
features three of the Batmans none of
the ones featured here unless there's a
big twist and I'm unprepared for a
live-action appearance of an actor in
this animated film but you can go to
shop zero
edition.com and pick yourself up some
bad first and you also enjoy us watching
this if you want to enjoy us watching
front to back start to finish with some
resting faces
then you become a super sexy reject over
at patreon and enjoy that whole shebang
it is gonna be awesome I am very excited
we will see you soon let's dive in to
Justice League do
foreign
crossover confusing everyone that's the
other Earth it's crisis in two words and
then it's them in the Marvel and you're
like why are we here what are we doing
Justice League dude
I choose to accept this Mission Mr Hunt
absolutely and Kevin Conroy
[Music]
there he is Guy Gardner himself Al
Jordan
I mean and the one casting like ripped
from so many of these animated movies
Carl lumbly hell yeah I love Carl Lumber
hey all right all right now Luther but
it's still good dude he's the Luthor
I'll take him as flash let's do this
Justice League Doom let's Doom this
yes this makes sense
it's the emails from Batman v Superman
ah it all comes together and all ties in
oh oh no should have driven there Batman
uh damn you Gambit
told you Dr Doom Marvel crossover this
is Batman I found them and tell cyborg
he was right about how they've been
breaking into these places Hold Your
Position help is on the way
yeah
whoa that's what I call a safe cracker
we don't want industrial Diamonds the
boss Listen To The King 10.
see you
[Music]
cute I can do this all day Oh Captain
America everybody take what you can and
get out right as soon as I kill Batman
that's gonna happen
oh smart
oh wait Batman came here alone I'm
supposed to be worried about Robin
those sleeves on my dude the shoulder
pads are really doing the work
oh yeah that's right crap it's the
Justice League
[Music]
that's their whole slogan crap it's the
Justice League
add that Queen
that leaves Jack haven't seen him since
he's sick days on me it couldn't have
gone far you search the Vault I'll take
the rest of the building but where's the
joke yeah not nice
[Music]
gauntlets the only one able to cancel
with cards Wonder Woman
I love that's how physics works
I love there she is flying card
hoverboards don't bother I just looked
everywhere the whole complex except for
the last Vault room shall we after you
like you've got a choice
good job I thought he got shot in the
face first wow it's over
you're gaming
[Music]
dang
[Applause]
God though like the bend and stretch of
this animation is fascinating say good
night Ace
surrender peacefully and you will not be
harmed really really don't sell Martian
oh
trying to make me look away it's not
gonna work phase phase Berry
[Music]
clotheslined him anything on the hard
drive a lot I'm still sorting it all out
wake up King
got some questions for you ah wake up
King I want a lawyer you're getting
ahead of yourself first you want a
doctor
who gave you the technology that allows
you to walk through walls I do not know
I know you don't like to do it Sean not
unnecessarily
I like it a lot in the right
circumstance I've read the minds of his
entire group none of them knows the
origin of the device I'll take these
guys to booking and the rest of you can
sleep on what we've learned I don't need
to sleep I need to follow up Bruce
a session with my healing Ray could save
you several days of recovery time I'm
fine Diana I take him up on the that
sounds great the Ray would so much more
productive you could search the hard
drive on the device for I've still got
16 petabytes of data to sort through
I'll call you as soon as I've got
something
that answers wants to work it's a
workaholic this guy let him rest okay
it's gonna go home and rearrange the bat
cave now
interesting Batman loses Nation not
going to let me go to work not until
you've had proper medical attention Fine
Food and a minimum of eight hours bed
rest let's just get this over with
I made chicken soup you can eat while
you brewed and I'll put in your stitches
Alfred is rye but I like them it's like
more Rye than you yeah a little extra
like oh I'm not gonna deal with your
Batman I've dealt with this for
so many years this is the most
entire plan
see-through guy you sure this thing will
work
the amount of money I paid lexcorp get
it better the information I sent you to
steal is far more valuable than Batman's
secret identity High sides I already
know it oh
who would Lex Corp and hmm it's got to
be Doctor Doom gotta be Doctor Doom only
man of mine now
skinny Bane yeah right it was a skinny
Luchador
sveltebane ah yes of course nobody's
shaming
deadbeat
whoa Star Sapphire
Spain isn't it I'm a taller scary guys
and the lady with a claws is cheetah
some kind of suicide
what is happening Doom welcome to the
hall of Doom
I'm Vandal Savage
this guy's back
you each have a personal Vendetta
against a member of the Justice League I
have a vision for this world and they
would stand in my way their deaths would
serve my goals
and any of you who would like to
continue working with me are welcome to
share in the reaches I don't see any of
us looking for the exit welcome to the
Legion of Doom Legion of Doom let's go
better live up to that name I have some
unpleasant news
but no how could this have happened
where are my parents caskets dark
um
you found it like this just a few
minutes ago no I called the house right
away whoever did this is going to pay
perhaps I can help you with that
yeah
I may have been lying what
about right give me my boy I think maybe
we actually surprised you I forgotten it
was my birthday also I'd never mentioned
it to any of you your stalker knows all
did you call him John is that John
Aarons I think so oh John Henry
I didn't order that it's from the lady
damn it
do you know her
I do not
I will no she just got you a cake you
seem very familiar I can't place your
face that's unusual for me really look
oh it's Jon Jones oh that makes sense
[Music]
yeah
what do you want cheetah to hurt you
Diana what else Ah that's my whole
purpose in these Comics I have one goal
every time
oh cool sweet
hey can we wrap this up we're blocking
traffic and it's obvious what happened
is it it's just that the facts don't fit
the scenario don't investigate the crime
scene again this guy's dead and I'm
alive alright mirror Masters robbing the
new maglev train from Keystone City bag
and tag everything and be thorough this
is a murder not an accident where you
going train station he's got a very
subtle secret identity
what's that ring on your hand yeah you
big flash fan I guess weird I've never
seen him in the same place yeah
oh hey they actually did it yeah I mean
that Ring's not gonna you itself they
call themselves The identity Brotherhood
they plan to use the salt mine as their
base during the second American
Revolution which is they claim imminent
it killed a dozen people and wounded
three of my men and seasoned so many
meals so many
not gonna make a Green Lantern
you're in a cake I know it was a perfect
opportunity
flashlight but you're in a cave Lantern
it up I know it's what you charged in
but it'll always be great the little
iconography yeah come on how often do
you get the lantern
took you long enough to get here I
brought you something
hologram
figures
which one of us is real
I don't care
punch them all
oh
dude
sometimes you gotta have your parents
Graves thrown at you in there you know
grave yep really get close to their
memory what we fought before I broke the
bat today I break the man
[Music]
your spirit or your body the whole man
she's still alive
don't move
at the end of the countdown already in
progress the Box will activate and
instantly kill the old woman it's a trap
most probably but you can't take that
chance
are you fast enough Flash
[Music]
oh
right through the wrist if you try to
remove the bomb it explodes if you do
nothing in 60 seconds it explodes once
you start running if you decelerate it
explodes speed it's laced with a
chemical that has an odd effect on
Martian biology you couldn't taste it
over the soda damn it your body will
filter about in a few hours
[Music]
don't you matter can't hold your liquor
stay back damn it you must get everyone
away from me you're all in grave danger
oh no no
please
stop drop and roll partner hang in there
look at this
where's bibo at that's not I thought it
was bar but I don't think it is that's
fine because I thought that was stealing
there for would be yeah Billow and
Superman's Metropolis but it wasn't
can you see him Jimmy wow
I think that guy works for our paper
good touch with the yeah shaky lens
vision
that's poor enough Lantern you make a
move and that drill is coming down on
their heads step away from the control
panel and you won't get hurt there's no
other way out of this
yeah try me
the shutoff is controlled from one of
the other consoles in this mine
this is like a maddening video game it
really is yeah
catch them catch the debris the old
anti-drill drill trick eh that bracelet
trick always impresses me
at least I got to you once
[Music]
up poisoned I can't thank himself
drugged me catch me if you can
it's not bad
oh damn it it's not possible mirror
Master trick but drugs
closer I'll do it
redundancy plan follow the light it's a
safe path back to the surface they've
still got Carol from bookkeeping they
took her hostage first make him a
lantern it would help see in the dark in
a cave it's a tool I'd use yeah it's
Gotta cast more spread than the string
yeah let's go
all your partners are captured or worse
you've got no options I've got one oh
oh damn bad
I don't understand why didn't I disarm
him oh no
yep oh this is bad man they got you all
between a rock and a hard place she sort
of looks like me doesn't she
what
her name was Carol too she's beautiful
of course and she has dark hair like
mine and the stench of your failure
hanging over her
I'm afraid
afraid that you don't deserve to have so
much power that nobody does no one man
should have all that power I hope you
have the decency to do what's right and
suffer for your many sins
a secret cat always suffering
[Music]
damn I don't think I've ever seen how
that emotional they've all got the exact
thing against them that they know would
break them newspapers are dying I spent
my life fighting for the little guy
fighting for truth and Justice in the
American way
[Music]
oh no
range
of course Kryptonite heart
[Music]
the disguises Legion of Doom
started out so fun and now I'm starting
to feel increases ominous yeah start off
all bouncy like a like a Justice League
episode yeah like oh this is a fun time
no no Jon Jones Is On Fire
flash that's right
God
bless the bottom of his hand
wow
you were concerned about where I put
your parents they're very close
rest in peace wow
so cruel
yes that thing doesn't have any
repressed Rage or problems with his
parents
get your uh Kill Bill on you know
the next stage of my plans might be
considered genocidal oh good destroy the
world nothing's so crude half two-thirds
at the most Thanos Savage yeah even
harder that I am old older than the
human race 80 000 years ago oh yeah
one night the sky lit up with streaks of
fire meteors but my primitive mind
thought the stars were falling from the
sky
oh yeah one meteor fell to Earth in my
Valley I slept there
bathed in the meteor of strange
radiations and when I awoke the next
morning I was forever changed the
radiation mutated me
evolving me I was instantly aware of my
increased intelligence again the
intellect of a modern human
working smart now guys yeah I cannot die
is that a fact go ahead
foreign
but I would so love it if you just like
that's the end of the movie credits you
know he talked to big girl game in his
new world our money doesn't matter it's
a good point you guys are all there for
that you are interested money won't
matter it's trivial in the long run
and I tried to kill you 75
000 years ago
a disaster newly rendered Humanity
extinct I Enslaved the survivors and
ruled with an iron hand
guys I did Pompeii I did my people were
well underway to repopulating the Earth
and becoming the planet's dominant
species tell them how to dance and how
to lift
those who survive will happily follow a
leader who offers food comfort and order
to you my Warlords I offer dominion over
as much of what remains of the planet as
each of you can hold
that's a loaded promise how do you
propose to kill that many people even
without the Justice League they will
fight they
hmm yeah I'm counting on them fighting
I have one large missile this missile is
Big we're okay it's a specialness
[Music]
why did you rob that grave that's what
it should have been damn good it's good
work yep so let's pretend I said it a
few scenes ago yeah
something at it it's there
take out all the civilians you think are
her why are you guys attacking Wonder
Woman she was fighting the cheetah then
suddenly started attacking everyone we
got the civilians out and the park
sealed off but we can't get anywhere
near her look at her she's having a
seizure or something no uh I'm gonna
talk her down pull your men back I feel
like cyborg is the only one who hasn't
been like directly challenged yeah I
wonder if he has got like a virus and
it's gonna activate or or if he will be
the key or if they didn't know about him
because he didn't seem like he was
always around whatever that weapon is
cheetah it won't work it's a scanner
something's happening to you did you
just call me cheetah
no uh she thinks I'm cheetah
they're broadcasting directly into your
Visual and auditory centers making you
see whatever cheetah wants you to I've
identified the frequency so I'm just
gonna broadcast
no
[Music]
like who talks like that likes me to do
this cheetah I don't know does it make
sense it's a rough situation I get why
she wouldn't believe it but also
yes
[Music]
hey cyborg you know with the one arm
you're ripped off as thus far resisted
all attempts to cut flash I need you to
go to Star Labs Kyoto and have them
Forge a piece of kryptonite into a
scalpel bring it to you can't help you
we got a bomb bolted to my wrist if I
stop it'll explode I've seen speed as
well
need your help
I'm on fire right now yes I've seen
Carrie as well yes
I'll forget the bad Wing ready the
Justice League is under attack by whom
fine
bites oh it's the things he devised to
take them out and Vandal Savage found it
so he knows how to kill them all and he
knows there's been his weaknesses his
family and he put him in the dick
damn it come on Batman I'm with cyborg
bring him with you the plans don't
account for him he could be the king oh
yeah see there you go how far away are
you from an iceberg I'm never far from
anything you think that'll slow it down
enough just
to make one misstep got it at least if
it doesn't work nobody dies with me and
the ozone it's not polar bears drinking
their Coca-Cola
[Music]
cheese poor guy
nicely done nicely done flag damn
could be worse
could be worse we can still save
Superman and Green Lantern if you do
exactly what I say got a contingency fan
for my anti-justice league contingency
plan that's how deep Batman's lair goes
man but what if the contingency plan on
the Batman contingency plan doesn't do
the Justice League intention Supply we
need to access contingency plans sub
level 108. call Batman Beyond it's
harmless to my Martian physiology but
ideal for neutralizing the Magnesium I
was secreting how did he know right now
you have to prep for surgery
surgery great comic where Batman made a
robot that could take out all the
Justice League and him if he ever lost
his mind so Batman has to fight this
robot that's the antithesis of all of
Batman smarts such a good run I was the
one whose arrogance led to this girl's
death I know more than a little about
arrogance I also know about dead bodies
and that isn't one oh oh
dang you were dosed with a synthesized
version of the scarecrow's fear gas
because will is the source of your
strength and fear is the enemy
fear is the mind killer it's true a
piece of kryptonite that you're going to
use like a lens narrow your blaster to
minimum and filter it through yes laser
surgery
that's good woof
oh that looks painful pay a lot of money
on that in certain uh internet circles
[Music]
big blue
he's in hologram form so whoever set
them up with that interdimensional lock
pick also gave mirror Master the means
encrypted files from the back computer
when my files are decrypted they call
home Louisiana swampland
oh The Big Easy
land of Doom fly into the sun trailing
magnetic resonance it will trigger a
solar flare that will propagate at light
speed along the magnetic Trail we've
left and eight and a half minutes later
utterly destroy the sunward-facing side
of the earth wow
and thanks to the accompanying
electromagnetic pulse any technology
more advanced than say the steam engine
will simply stop working that's quite an
ambitious plan
he should have been burning for weeks
actually none of you managed to finish
the job did you get all that
[Music]
only fight your own villains not other
people you could take out more easily
yes now they're too much crossover Come
On Let's cross over it's the climax
[Music]
yeah I mean yeah go tick on cheetah or
something you'll be defined I still
can't believe what you tried to do to me
you hurt me Jordan you broke my heart
and I'll never stop trying to hurt you
back gotta let go of them grudges man
[Music]
oh it's like an anime now it's all
tentacles
that's new
I do love mirror man's like translucent
look yeah it's pretty cool
[Music]
yes tail truly the Cape of the animal
kingdom
[Music]
cool
star oh he's here
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
where's the flipping countdown command
come on missile launch aborted no
[Music]
foreign
devil always knows the wick you never
asked me how my wrist was healing hmm
fine
how's your
manual launch sequence engaged
yes beat that crane game cyborg
[Music]
always looks so painful
yeah I've never seen it red before
[Music]
as a badass kick yeah
all right Batman I'll stop a rocket yeah
grab on to it it's on you what's
Superman doing is he still fighting
Metallo
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that was really cool with the cat's
cradle yeah
[Music]
hey
I do keep hurting you don't I Savage
launched the weapon Superman's already
in Pursuit on it it still seem like a
job maybe for the two here
oh no
[Music]
let's go soups
he's so charged up
thank you
no stop the magnetic Trail or whatever
love that magnetic Trail by the way blow
some ice breath on it or something the
solar flare is coming out how to stop it
oh no but we've got less than eight
minutes to figure something out Batman
maybe longer oh what do you got
[Music]
I know how they intended to survive the
intangibility techie gave the royal
flush game it must have been a test run
sure
the Hall of Doom is the apparatus can
this building generate a signal strong
enough to make the whole earth
intangible if we had enough power also
it would help if it were higher up I can
help you out with that yes now you're
working like a team
thank you
[Music]
the displacement field ready I think so
I'd like to test this is the test this
is the test roll on rehearsal gang get
in one
come out
damn
is at the same place it was a seafood
place a seafood place not paper it was
the other one still no demo
is he okay
it's a very cool visual
[Music]
oh hey leave a like
the world court has just found Vandal
Savage guilty of crimes against humanity
tell them what the immortal God life in
prison he is I want to officially
welcome the newest member of the Justice
League by unanimous consent cyborg
welcome
all done Bud now Batman knows how to
kill you yep that's how you get in it's
your welcome package we have to decide
whether Batman should be allowed to
remain in the league before we vote I
think the accused should be allowed a
few words in his defense my actions
don't require any defense in the same
situation I do it again
huh
man if you people can't see the
potential danger of an out-of-control
Justice League I don't need to wait for
a vote especially after what we dealt
with like with the crime assist crime
League or whatever they're called crime
syndicate my contingencies were intended
to immobilize not kill but Savage came
up with a plan to bury you I assume so
it wasn't one of mine my plan for me is
way better I would have done this you're
still so arrogant you didn't bother to
come up with a plan to stop yourself I
do have a plan
it's called The Justice League
just wanted to be sure
I don't have any innate super abilities
you guys should be able to take care of
me pretty easily I'm just a guy I'm a
guy in a suit a bad suit I want there to
be somebody I can trust to keep the
planet safe even from me
wow
wow that is Trust
oh hey oh I didn't realize it was that I
knew we'd pass but I didn't think it was
like 2011. wow
holy that was great that was a lot of
fun oh very much enjoyed that
oh Dennis off was mirror Maps yeah that
makes sense that's a very unique voice
and Bruce Tim was Ace how that went down
a little bit a little bit at the top
there I thought it was Ace the bat Hound
I was like I was like Ace was in and
spoke also was like was there a barking
in the
in the back yeah yeah the Royal flesh
they were like Jack queen king Ace yeah
look at this
look at them it's like the George
Clooney South Park camp yeah or whatever
that is what just happened oh that's so
funny I left
uh that was fun yeah I liked two Arts a
bit more uh yeah sure but this uh this
was really cool to like have some of the
OG voice actors back the ones that like
we really like in these roles like
Rosenbaum and obviously the one and only
Batman of Animation there are many many
other great Batman but like there's no
one quite like Kevin Conroy
um and Nathan Fillion such a such a
formative Green Lantern and uh Susan
Eisenberg was the the name I remember
from the other one Roman she's great
it's such a clear like crisp voice but
yeah this was um the voice acting is
fantastic I honestly think the voice
acting was a little bit stronger in the
animation uh do you feel like the
animation was a little on the on the
underfunded side at points uh there were
some times that like the physics didn't
seem to follow its own rules or like
certain positioning and like you know
there were there were elements that felt
like it was a little uh lower budget but
the writing was so good and the and the
acting was so good I was able to like
kind of re-engage
um but yeah I really enjoyed this I love
the story of of you know Batman's
fail-save comic which I referenced a
little ago um it was not long ago it was
actually the current run of Batman by
chipset RC is only on issue like 13 that
was issues one through six this is only
like a one-year-old comic like this is a
new run and it's called Fail-Safe and
it's the idea that Batman
has those contingencies for everything
else and the Fail-Safe for him is this
robot that can defeat him and all of
them so I've always loved the idea that
Batman I mean we've referenced it like
Batman out thinking everyone like 3D
chess so many moves ahead yeah totally
and uh and this was a really cool use of
that story I really enjoyed this yeah I
did too this this was one that was
interesting because this started out in
a way where I was like okay this is
going to be a little lighter a little
bit more just like ah you know is it
kind of a fun outing it felt more like
oh we're watching like the animated
series or something right now and then
as it went and as it really picked up
steam and as you really got to
understand what the master plan was with
Vandal Savage and the uh the leak of
Doom and all that stuff like I it
started to sing and it started to kind
of rise to that level of you know what
you'd expect out of a crisis on Two like
crisis on Two Earths is such like a it
feels like such a crisp sort of event
movie yeah sort of have a direct sequel
I think at first I was a little taken
aback I was like okay this feels like
just kind of another adventure and it
sort of ties in because they have this
interdimensional you know Tech involved
but yeah like as it slowly started to be
revealed that like oh okay this is the
master plan is to yeah use Batman's
contingencies and warp them so that they
are death plans instead of just
neutralization plans and watching as
each member of the Justice League is you
know brought to their knees and is is
overcome and is you know met with their
you know deepest vulnerabilities like
yeah it just this was like a grower it
really started to hum and sing and yeah
it's like the crisis on tours I
definitely remember sitting there going
like wow man just some of these
animation flourishes and some of this
yeah
yeah it's like this one has a little
there were a couple moments where I'd
find myself noticing like oh wow what a
what a smooth you know motion shot or or
what an interesting little like you know
yeah Bend and squash kind of flourish or
something but it does overall feel yeah
a little bit more downgraded on that
sense not just slightly like there are a
lot of still really lovely designs and
things like that but maybe not as like
visually striking as some of them have
been although I still appreciate you
know this era as opposed to like the
dcamu which is much more modern like I
still styled the classic animation I
want to look at one thing real quick to
make sure that I have the right name
um but yeah I agree with what you're
saying and I and I do think like the
moment we were both struck by the
animation when like the planet and
everything else we definitely were both
like whoa that's really cool so there
were definitely moments of flourish and
moments that like really sang that made
it at work
um but at the same time I I did notice
that I was distracted by something
animation at points uh yeah that's fair
that's absolutely fair I'm ninety
percent sure ninety five percent sure
yes uh Dwayne McDuffie invented static
shock okay cool cool so uh he also did
Ben 10 which is what I was trying to
check on so uh
I knew the static shock but I didn't
want to be wrong about Ben 10 because
that's something I like I I love Ben 10
because nobody Yuri voiced him um but
Justice League Unlimited Ben 10 as well
as uh as the great static shock we're
doing McDuffie so I actually knew him
from static and uh then he's a fantastic
comic book writer as well but yeah so
it's a it's a bummer to I I didn't
realize he'd been passed for 12 years
that's that's pretty crazy but I love
that they gave this you know a little
love to him as the writer of this and
this definitely felt like a classic DC
experience and adventure and like this
felt like that kind of like classic
animated romp and experience so yeah I
mean it was a lot of fun but I
definitely I think we've been uh I mean
we've been living in this animated world
for like 20 of these uh 25 almost so
like when they're when they're these
cinematic Opus is like what we just
experienced when it goes down to a
little bit smaller budget you notice
yeah and I mean this was one where I
thought it kind of wrote a line where I
was you know some of them you're like
wow how did they manage to fit all this
into an hour and 10 minutes or whatever
and this was one where yeah I'm like
this is this all yeah it didn't feel
too slight for what it is but it didn't
feel like oh wow how'd you manage you
know and and I think that the for again
the from my experience that that grower
quality that sort of like it picks up
momentum it picks up steam it gets
better as it goes I think kind of helps
that to feel sort of more natural rather
than like ah like a letdown or something
like that
um yeah it feels like a little bit
smaller a little more contained The
Master episode yeah exactly it
definitely feels like a big long episode
I wonder if it ever was because at one
point they like re-explained a moment
like they felt like a commercial break
where they're like Batman's the one that
did it and then they cut to them in the
space thing they're like and
they're like let's make it a movie yeah
maybe and maybe they aired this like
split apart right pieces and never had
to like plan for that or something which
is also kind of a fun feeling because I
do like a nice Saturday morning cartoon
feeling yeah 100 no this is it's a it's
it's well at home within the Spectrum I
feel like and yeah it's like it reaches
a few Heights that do feel like that you
know sort of Hefty intensity that you
expect out of some of the biggest you
know event stories that we've seen thus
far
um and I thought that like the most
striking stuff he has like Batman's
contingency and the way that the like
the villains become more interesting
when you realize like oh they've stolen
his plan and are now going to wipe out
half the Earth it's like the the Vandal
Savage stuff
you know I feel like he could be more of
a character yeah you know like all that
I'm a caveman yeah it's like I really
liked watching them fight and I really
liked the pair offs and and watching
everyone struggle and then overcome and
come back together as a team and really
work as a team and and figuring out how
to stop the solar flare like that stuff
I I thought really started to rise to
that sort of harmonious level where
you're just not thinking about anything
else yeah so yeah it's like certain
parts of this could have been more
developed but I feel like we've seen
stuff that's also less developed than
this sure um so yeah this was like this
is pretty decent and I liked yeah
especially just that hook of of what if
Batman's contingency plan fell into the
wrong hands yeah the fact that they at
least talk about it afterwards and this
iteration the Justice League I think is
nice where you got a little bit more
from Martian Manhunter you got cyborg
being inducted here and I like that
Dynamic too he's not accounted for in
this and that's part of the key yeah
but yeah yeah I agree I really enjoyed
that element and I love these casts uh
relationships I like their their
familiarity with each other this feels
like the Justice League yeah so yeah I
had a great time uh this was really fun
if you guys have any others you want us
to check out we've been reading your
comments and seeing this was actually
one of the ones a lot of you recommended
so we jump on into it please let us know
in the comments below hit that like hit
that notification Bell and hit that
share button because we want to keep
making these there are 50 some uh DC
Animated Universe films we're hitting
that like 25 26 for somewhere in that
range so we want to keep cranking
through them so let us know what you
want us to check out next before we
leave we got a patron of the day shout
out who we got who we got
Ricardo Martinez
Bane was in this movie yeah Bane was in
this movie and I feel like he is one of
the very few I mean you got Blue Beetle
sure you got Bane how many more Hispanic
Heroes and Rogues are there Zorro that's
the only thing I got a problem with is
the Blue Beat of marketing they're like
it's the first uh Latin American
superhero I'm like zoro's the first
superhero like like yeah yeah okay
inspired Batman okay so that's true
right but you know who inspired them all
is freaking Ricardo Martinez all right
he's the original he's the 00g that's
right you're the archetype for all
formidable Latin characters
absolutely you were there at the
beginning of time and then you were
bestowed this sort of magic energy that
unlocked all of your potential and then
everybody else in the world was like we
gotta cut it
thank you for enlightening us thank you
for blessing us with your prowess your
knowledge your Acumen and your
formidable talents and uh thank you for
supporting us here at the patreon
appreciate you being here and uh yeah
stay pledged that's the ultimate plan no
matter how much of the Earth you might
be wiping out or who you might be
attempting to save I feel like the
pledge
I hope this building is uh the the thing
that transfers the power through like we
we're safe here with Ricardo Martinez
position of course if you wait to the
right time of day of course wait till
like the middle of the night okay like
write it like 10 p.m our time I think we
should be good we have enough time to
kind of Outlast the ray so Ricardo if
you could arrange that would very much
appreciate if it's convenient yeah all
right that's going to do it to lovelies
we will see you next time for whatever's
next
foreign
[Music]